, BRIAN, AINSLEY, STEVE?
BRIAN:  GOOD JOB, GRIFF AS USUAL
LET’S BRING IN SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
CAN I GET YOUR TAKE ON WHAT THE
SPEAKER WANTS TO DO?
DO WE NEED A FOURTH RESCUE
PACKAGE?
>> WELL WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PHASE III ACTUALLY WORKS,
WE DON’T HAVE ANY CHECKS OUT YET
THE UNEMPLOYMENT PART OF PHASE
III, I’M VERY WORRIED ABOUT.
EVERY STATE HAS THE UNEMPLOYMENT
COMMISSION TO ISSUE UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECKS.
THERE WERE 3 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT LAST WEEK
AND THERE WILL BE MORE THIS WEEK
I’M VERY CONCERNED THAT IT MAY
TAKE SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS TO GET
AN UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK, AND
DOWN THE ROAD, YOU’RE PAYING
PEOPLE MORE THAN THEY ACTUALLY
MAKE.
WE’VE GOT TO FIX BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS SO I THINK THE
TRAIN WRECK IN THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFIT, BECAUSE IT’S
ADMINISTERED BY STATE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE STUCK IN THE 70S SO I
WANT TO GET PHASE III RIGHT
BEFORE WE GO TO PHASE IV.
AINSLEY: SENATOR THERE WAS TALK
OF PEOPLE GETTING A SECOND CHECK
DOWN THE ROAD, IF THERE IS A
PHASE IV, WOULD THAT BE A PART
OF IT, DO YOU THINK THERE WILL
BE ANOTHER CHECK THAT
INDIVIDUALS WILL GET?
>> IT MIGHT BE BUT THESE CHECKS
GO TO PEOPLE WITH JOBS.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OUT OF WORK.
I GOT A NIECE WORKING IN SOUTH
CAROLINA MAKES ABOUT $40,000 A
YEAR, YOU KNOW, QUITE FRANKLY,
SHE’S OKAY.
BUT SOMEBODY LAID OFF NEEDS THE
MONEY, SO THESE DIRECT
PAYMENTS GO TO PEOPLE WITH
INCOME.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON PEOPLE
WITHOUT INCOME.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY IS BROKEN
I’M GOING TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO FIX IT.
SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS TO GET A
CHECK IS WHAT I’M HEARING AND
THAT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE AND END
UNEMPLOYMENT UNDER THIS BILL
YOU’RE ACTUALLY INCREASING
PEOPLE’S WAGES WHICH WILL DETER
GROWING THE ECONOMY.
WE GOT TO FIX BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY BUT SENATOR
YOU KNOW, YOU’VE BEEN IN
WASHINGTON FOR A LONG TIME, YOU
KNOW HOW WHEN A BIG BILL LIKE
PHASE IV COMES ALONG, SUDDENLY
IT’S LIKE WHAT’S IN IT FOR ME?
AND YOU KNOW, FOR NANCY PELOSI,
WE TALKED ABOUT SHE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE INFRASTRUCTURE, FRONTLINE
WORKERS, AID TO WASHINGTON D.C.
IS THAT APPROPRIATE GIVEN WHAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED?
WELL WHAT I WANT TO DO IS
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED IN THE LAST
48 HOURS THAT THE DISEASE IS
WORSE THAN THE CURE?
I DON’T WANT TO HEAR ANYBODY
ELSE COMPARE THIS TO THE FLU ANY
MORE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DECIDED TO
EXTEND SOCIAL DISTANCING THROUGH
THE END OF APRIL.
WHY?
BECAUSE IF WE DO NOTHING
2.2 BILLION PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
DIE OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S 40 YEARS OF FLU DEATHS IN
ONE YEAR.
SO THIS IS A TERRIBLE DISEASE.
THE CURE HAS TO BE TOUGH, SO THE
IDEA OF CREATING PHASE IV
BEFORE YOU UNDERSTAND IF PHASE
III WORKS DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE
TO ME.
I’M HOPING THAT WHAT WE’RE DOING
NOW IN APRIL AND MAY WILL SLOW
THE DISEASE DOWN, COME SUMMER,
THE HEAT WILL STOP ITS SPREAD
AND BY THE FALL WE’LL BE READY
TO GO AT IT WITH THERAPIES AND
VACCINES BUT BEFORE I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT PHASE IV, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE PHASE III WORKS AND IF
ANYBODY PUTS A DIME IN PHASE IV
UNRELATED TO THE VIRUS, THEY’RE
GOING TO BE VERY FAMOUS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE DYING IN THIS COUNTRY
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO DO THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
IF THERE’S ANY GREEN NEW DEAL
STUFF IN PHASE IV, IF THERE IS A
PHASE IV, THERE WILL BE ONE HELL
OF A FIGHT BECAUSE 2.2 MILLION
AMERICANS LIVES ARE AT RISK HERE
BRIAN:  ABSOLUTELY BUT THE GUN
WAS TO EVERYBODY’S HEAD.
SENATOR THIS STARTED IN CHINA
AND CHINA HAS NOT OWNED UP TO
THIS.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO ABOUT
THIS?
HOW MUCH CONTROL DO WE HAVE OF
STOPPING THE NEXT VIRUS FROM
COMING THROUGH?
>> WELL I’M GOING TO WRITE A
LETTER TO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION INTO THE CHINESE
AMBASSADOR ASKING THEM TO CLOSE
THE CHINESE WET MARKET.
THESE ARE OPEN AIR MARKETS WHERE
THEY SELL MONKEY, THEY SELL BAT,
WE THINK THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED WITH A TRANSMISSION FROM
A BAT TO A HUMAN, ABOUT THE LAST
THREE OR  FOUR PANDEMICS HAVE
COME FROM THE CHINESE WET
MARKETS.
I DON’T THINK THIS CAME FROM A
CHINESE MILITARY LAB, BUT THESE
WET MARKETS ARE GROSS, THEY ARE
JUST ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING,
SELLING EXOTIC ANIMALS THAT
TRANSMIT VIRUSES FROM ANIMALS TO
HUMAN BEINGS.
THOSE THINGS NEED TO SHUT DOWN.
AINSLEY: DO YOU THINK THAT’S
GOING TO DO ANY GOOD?
THERE’S BEEN CONTROVERSY WITH
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
DO YOU THINK CHINA IS REALLY
GOING TO LISTEN?
>> WELL I THINK WE SHOULD, I’M
GOING TO WRITE A LETTER TO THE
CHINESE AMBASSADOR SAYING IF YOU
DON’T SHUT THOSE WET MARKETS
DOWN OUR TRADING RELATIONSHIP IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
THE SOURCE OF THIS VIRUS IS THE
CHINESE WET MARKETS BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE DOCTORS WHO COME ON AND
ASK THEM HOW MANY DISEASES HAVE
COME FROM CHINA THROUGH THESE
WET MARKETS WHERE YOU INTER
MINGLE ALL KINDS OF EXOTIC
ANIMALS, IT’S JUST REALLY A
GROSS DISPLAY OF HOW YOU PREPARE
FOOD, THAT NEEDS TO STOP.
WHAT CAN CHINA DO TO HELP THE
WORLD?
SHUT THOSE MARKETS DOWN.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF SHUT DOWN,
SENATOR WHAT ABOUT YOUR OFFICE?
IS IT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
THING?
IS EVERYBODY WORKING FROM HOME
OR  WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> WE HAVE MOST PEOPLE WORKING
FROM HOME BUT WE HAVE ALL THE
OFFICES MANNED, WE’RE TRYING
TO COMMUNICATE THE BEST WE CAN
BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE AT THE
OFFICES, OUR GOVERNORS DONE A
GOOD JOB HERE, WE’RE TRYING TO
ABIDE BY THE GUIDELINES.
I HOPE BY APRIL 30 WE’LL HAVE
TURNED THE CORNER HERE, BUT THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION TO
EXTEND SOCIAL DISTANCING THROUGH
APRIL 30 WAS BASED ON SOUND
SCIENCE, AND HERE IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT REALIZED.
THIS IS NOT THE FLU.
2.2 MILLION PEOPLE COULD DIE IN
A SINGLE YEAR.
THAT IS FLU DEATHS SO THE CURE
IN THIS CASE HAS TO BE DRACONIAN
BECAUSE THE DISEASE IS SO DEADLY
TESTING HAS CHANGED, THAT’S GOOD
NEWS.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF TESTS
AVAILABLE NOT THOUSANDS.
WE DO IT IN MINUTES NOT DAYS SO
WE’RE TURNING THE CORNER IN
TESTING AND THE SOONER WE GET
MORE TESTS THE MORE NORMAL
AMERICA WILL BECOME.
BRIAN:  YEAH, I CAN NOT WAIT FOR
THAT DAY.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, THANKS
FOR LEADING THE CHARGE ON THIS.